introducing Apple watch Series three and
it has cellular built-in now you have
the freedom to go anywhere with just
your Apple watch with just your Apple
watch
Oh at least the alarm sounds nice it's
gonna be a long day
oh wait that's the series two Apple
watch I don't know how I missed the red
dot here to tell me that this is the
brand-new $400 cellular version pretty
disappointing that this doesn't look any
different here browser tracker steps
okay no iPhone at all all day I can do
this I can do this all right a quick
mile and a half air pods in workout
started and workout mix on unfortunately
the streaming music feature isn't out
until next month that's what I'm really
looking forward to look mom no phone
okay this feels wonderful I've always
run with the phone in case of an
emergency
hey Siri text Chris I'm running ten
minutes late meet you at the dock
what you don't go jet skiing every
morning comfortable this is gonna be
awesome and away we go
no jetski workout and so James Bond yeah
I don't care if my phone is waterproof
I'd be petrified if it were in my pocket
right now on the other hand I'd have a
camera to take this awesome photo with
oh good two bars of t-mobile service out
here let's try a phone call I'm in the
middle of the Hudson River call me back
not cool at least this thing it's still
very waterproof hmm I've just randomly
lost cellular connectivity that's a
problem wait and I'm already at 65%
battery I'm gonna make it through the
day I'm gonna need to be prepared with a
giant mobile backup battery this should
do it of course if I had my iphone
nearby or if I was on Wi-Fi the watch's
battery would last throughout the whole
day wish me luck guys there we go again
with dropping connectivity let's try
switching on and off cellular that seems
to do the trick very frustrating Apple
says we haven't seen this in any of our
testing and we're looking into it after
I published my video Apple gave me this
statement we have discovered that when
Apple watch series three joins
unauthenticated Wi-Fi networks without
connectivity it may at times prevent the
watch from using cellular we are
investigating a fix for a future
software release need coffee when I get
an almond latte huh who needs it phone
okay maybe I need a phone yeah he's
jealous okay this is gonna be tough
Oh responding to male voice to text is
probably the best route or just hi not
bad what's up okay I gotta go my wrist
is burning hot okay that's an
exaggeration but the watch does get very
warm during longer calls no one I'd
rather eat lunch with guess I'm not
checking Instagram or Twitter
not even solitaire that doesn't even
need the Internet hey Siri get me
directions to trapeze school New York
[Music]
all right Apple watch this is my big
test
time to fly what better way to test the
altimeter and heart rate monitor have I
mentioned I'm scared of heights I don't
know why I thought this was a good idea
oh god he did it very nervous that's
okay
157 beats per minute I actually believe
it ready I don't think I can do it yeah
you can't go for the things I do for
testing by the way the watch accurately
measured my steps up the ladder I'm good
I'm good uh I phone I missed you so much
Apple watch this was an interesting
experiment you're certainly more
independent than I thought you'd be and
I really did like having you on my wrist
for those extreme sports at least when
you worked but until your cellular
issues are fixed I can't recommend you
goodnight Apple watch there's always the
330 dollar series 3 without cellular or
the series 4